[MUSIC PLAYS]
DANNY JECK: Hi, I'm Danny Jeck.
I'm a fifth year grad
student getting my PhD
at Johns Hopkins in
biomedical engineering.
My project, what I'm
trying to look into
is how attention is related
to models of visual cortex.
The first lecture
was by Jim DiCarlo.
He gave a talk about how the
models of object recognition
seem to match pretty
well with the behavior
of inferotemporal
cortex in macaques.
We know that also in
macaques earlier areas
of visual processing are
modulated by attention.
So the question is, well, OK.
We have this model, let's
say we add some modulation
due to attention,
what does that do
downstream as that information
propagates through the network?
I'm building a model
in Python right now.
And it's running.
The main goal of
the model is to see
how some modulation
in earlier cortex
would propagate through a
model like what we believe is
happening in the brain already.
A boring finding would be
that a 10% modulation results
in a 10% modulation downstream.
I'm expecting that that's
not the case, because there's
a whole bunch of nonlinearities
and normalization
that happens that should
propagate through this network.
The question is what is
the magnitude of that,
how does that affect things
if the 10% modulation is not
actually the right number
because of some measurements
or the way I'm interpreting
the measurements that
have been made already, what
would different numbers allow
for.
Or perhaps the modulations
we found downstream are all
due to other feedback
from other areas
rather than this going
back to the beginning
and propagating all
the way through.
So the idea came about
from Ethan Meyers.
He was originally
interested in trying
to do this kind of two
passes through a network, one
in which you sort
of try and figure
out the location of an object,
and another in which you
try to recognize it.
I kind of took that in
a different direction
because I was more interested
in the neurophysiology side
of things.
In my current lab, I wouldn't
have had time to do something
like this because
I wasn't planning
on investing a lot
of time understanding
what deep networks were.
So really, having the time to
sort of work on a free project
has been really nice.
[MUSIC PLAYS]